[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much that was a really
sweet intro thanks for coming to my talk
I know that this is towards the end of
the day I've heard many naps have been
taken this afternoon so for those who
came back from their naps to join thank
you so much I'm very excited to take you
through an introduction hopefully as
gently as I can to web USB so I did
actually have an alternative title for
this and if you want to know the meaning
behind it I will explain to you after
this at the after party but what it
really wanted to color was how do you
send a singer and in this the browser
because that definitely has a little bit
of relevancy web USB but before I just
wanted to introduce myself super quickly
if you don't know of me my name is Suze
Hinton
I am new cat or no up cat on the
internet you can say it either way it's
definitely okay to say it either way I
work on open source IOT libraries in my
spare time a lot of them are in
JavaScript which is why I'm here today
if you came to the node bots workshop
yesterday thank you I was really happy
to see you there it was really fun
you saw me really badly explaining
certain components in the morning so
that was a lot of fun but during the day
I do have to Anna celery in order to pay
my rent so I am in developer relations
at Microsoft and I actually do focus on
I would say that too but it's more
security based and IOT in the cloud and
a lot of enterprise stuff as well so if
you're really interested to talk to me
about that later - he couldn also come
up to me I wanted to also think that
organizers you may have noticed that I'm
was not originally on the schedule so I
was asked to give this talk a week ago
so it just bear with me because some of
the demos are a little rough to you so
I'll explain that later on as well so
it's today's aim is to help you see the
browser and the web in a different way
I've definitely seen a lot of talks at
this conference so far that are along
those lines which i think is really
really cool and I want you to not be
scared of hardware and microcontrollers
because if I can hustle this in like
less than a week then you can definitely
do it it might take a little bit longer
if you're a beginner but the world of
hardware is getting ever and ever closer
to browsers and that's why I'm really
excited to tell you about that today so
the topics were actually going to cover
just a history of like web and devices
and how we've been like attempting to
clumsily smash them together in the past
what web USB is how to use web USB and
then like maybe some kind of futures
stuff that I'm hoping to see and how you
can kind of help provide a future for it
as well so first of all history of web
USB and when I beam by that is like
somehow being able to put browses and
like devices like arduino x' and drones
and boats and things like that together
in the past so we do actually have to go
as far back as 2007 to 2009 that was
when I first started getting into
hardware and trying to sort of make
really cool machines but also like talk
to it with my browser and so the way
that you did it back then was use flash
communication server does anyone use
that yeah a couple of us were certain to
be in the minority and you use this
really cool app called serve proxy and
what it would do is it would take the
serial port data coming in from like
something like an Arduino and it would
then like proxy that on to like
basically like a socket so that you
could actually listen to the data coming
in in your browser or in flash which is
really really interesting
so you would have your Arduino and your
browser but that was so far apart
because you had to have all these steps
in between right so you had so proxy
which would go from serial to TCP so
that you could then use flash
communication server and make a flash
app to listen to that so I think the
first example I ever did was I had like
a a trim pot like a little knob that you
could turn plugged into the Arduino and
when you turned it there was like a
circle colored in with a color in flat
and as you as you turn the knob it would
either change the cycle through all the
colors or it would change the shape of
the circle and I thought I was a wizard
basically if the code did not look much
like what a wizard would write there was
a really weird configuration file that
you used in so proxy where you had to
put lots of nerdy things like the baud
rate and all your stop bits and parity
and things like that but the flash
communication stuff in action script is
pretty readable you know you can kind of
see what's happening and so it was
actually pretty friendly once you
actually got that data coming through
but we all know what happened with flash
it fell out of vogue for like very you
know understandable reasons and I agree
with a lot of those reasons and so sadly
I sort of had to put that method down
and it was really uncool for a while for
me to say that I used to be a flash
developer for my day job so we fast
forward to 2013 to 2017 and we got this
really cool thing in the Chrome browser
called chrome serial and just wanted to
just quickly like before everyone gets
excited just to give a little bit of a
rest and peace there so explain what
happens later okay so let's start with
that scenario again you know we've got a
load we know and we desperately want our
browser to like start controlling it and
showing data and stuff like that so what
we would do is we would use Chrome
serial which was an API that allowed us
to access the the actual like serial
communication that was built into our
dueño boards or any other hardware that
had like a serial port that we could
connect to and then the only way that we
could actually use that API was it was
sort of sandboxed into you I either had
to have a chrome app and it had to sort
of run in there so for a while there
were like really cool things coming out
where you had a website but you also had
to kind of install the companion app and
it was a little bit clunky but I was
able to sort of demonstrate some of my
hardware libraries working within that
and some people went on to kind of use
my libraries to make really cool stuff
and one example that I really really
loved was the chip computer which some
of you might have seen on Kickstarter a
few years ago it was a $9
Linux computer and when you actually got
it in the mail you know it takes a while
as we know with Kickstarter's I used to
work there so I definitely I think I've
backed one hundred and thirtysomething
things who knows there they had this
really cool chrome app that when you
plug in your chip you know you could
just go and install this app and run it
in your browser and then you could
update the firmware in there and I was
like wow this hardware interface here
looks SuperDuper friendly it just
doesn't look scary like those weird
malware looking apps that you normally
have to download you know you know it's
so like update just like this one simple
thing and so you know if you're a hobby
collector of however you have all of
these ridiculous applications just
littered in your all over your hard
drive and you use them once and you just
never you forget about them so I think
at one point I had like six different
versions of the Arduino IDE running four
different machines that only required a
certain version so it's a nightmare
but speaking of Arduino and I know that
there's Arduino people here I caught up
with them earlier it's really cool do we
know actually went and created this app
that it's basically a living chrome app
that runs on Chrome OS devices which
means that you can program Arduino
boards now in the browser with a full
IDE and then you can compile and upload
that onto the board and that's using
Chrome serial and I thought that was so
so very cool and their Arduino create
platform is just like genius I just
actually think it's a better experience
than the normal audrina ID which has
been around for a while which was sort
of like based on the processing ID and
cool fact like they actually used my
software or at least they they have been
in the past you notice to flash the
Arduino so that was really awesome to
kind of see my stuff like browser fired
up a web packed or whatever and and put
into a chrome app but you can kind of
sense that that's a limitation like only
being able to run that on a Chrome App
just doesn't mean that you know it's
available to everybody so you know it
wasn't an official website either again
as I said it only worked in Chrome apps
which is a pretty narrow ecosystem these
days because they've sunset chrome apps
for just browsers and it only works when
Chrome OS and so that happened in
20:17 and there were a lot of really
really really really sad no buts people
that yeah so and so yes so that brings
us to today and what we've been kind of
doing up until web USB which is browsers
and web sockets so who went to the the
was it the smartphone Symphony earlier
yeah it was pretty cool wasn't it yeah
so we do the same thing with hardware
where we use WebSockets and we have like
a node server running you know on our
laptop and then we have our browser and
our back-end kind of node server is
speaking by a serial to the Arduino it
could be johnny-five or something like
that and then it's sending just like
messages through to the browser and the
browser can also send messages back so
it's just like your own kind of invented
protocol for figuring out how to like
you know how that two-way communication
and that works okay because I feel like
there's less distance between the
Arduino and the browser in this case and
we are writing JavaScript the whole way
too which is helpful but again you can
still see that there's just a few steps
in order to get going
you can alternatively package all of
this up into something like an electron
app or an N wjs app this is a piece of
software I made for a Kickstarter
project a while ago the the project is
called the public radio it is a radio in
a mason jar and it is a monogamous radio
where you can only listen to one radio
station
and so you can imagine people like I
changed my mind you know I'm I'm ready
to break up with NPR and I want to
listen to something else so you know
they had to offer some software in order
to like change the radio station right
and if you moved countries then you
would have to update the band or the
frequency or like you know radio is very
complicated if you've ever checked out
the Wikipedia page and so I created this
kind of proof of concept electron app
for them but it was like a hundred
megabytes so download just to change
this radio station and I'm like I'm just
contributing to the detritus of one off
apps that are like living on people's
hard drives and it just didn't feel
right but this was I was like I can feel
it I can smell it was so close to being
able to use web technologies you know
with node in it and JavaScript and it
feels good and even you can technically
use Arduino to create on you know a
computer other than a chrome book but it
does still have to run like a background
app that runs in your tray that kind of
is able to listen on a socket to be able
to kind of flash your Arduino so it's
again a better experience than the
Arduino ID but it's still having this
like coupling in between right and
that's as you can tell from the theme of
this that's what's been frustrating a
lot of us this whole time so now we kind
of see some of the problems that we've
had in the past which you might not have
actually been part of if you haven't
done hobby before hopefully that helps
you understand why web USB now is such a
big deal
and just to let you know I will remind
you of this later Web USB is a an
implementation of a different type of
communication than serial it's just that
you know Sarah was kind of like what we
had before this so come and see me if
you want to sort of know about the
differences of them later on so I'm
gonna be pulling from the web USB spec a
lot because I think that this spec is
extremely unique in that it has human
readable paragraphs and information in
it and I think it's really well written
and one of the main authors Riley I had
the pleasure of like he knows speaking
back and forth with on the internet
recently and that's something that he
deeply cares about and so I definitely
this is one of the only times I'm going
to encourage you to check out a spec
because I think it's really great so I'm
going to just like pull the main
messaging
from it so you can understand so the web
USB API provides a way to safely expose
USB to vice services to the web it's
pretty straightforward what's cool is
that it provides an API familiar to
developers who have used existing native
USB libraries and exposes the device
interfaces defined by existing
specifications so what I like about this
is rather than just reinventing the
wheel and saying well we're going to use
USB but we're gonna have our own thing
and we're gonna like invent this thing
for the JavaScript community they just
basically said we're a Melissa you know
device manufacturers we're aiming this
at people who already know what this
stuff is if we just use the same specs
then it's probably got a better chance
of success and it's going to be you know
it's it's cross-platform knowledge I
think that's really really cool it is a
little harder to learn as a result but
it just means that that knowledge can
actually be portable to other platforms
such as just writing like you know on
the bare operating system which is kind
of cool
so again web USB is different to serial
they're just different ways of
interfacing with devices web USB is more
like the lower-level stuff that most
professionally manufactured devices know
how to speak that being said it's not
you know super mega complex to learn so
why is web USB better than all of this
stuff that I offered you know as
solutions to you just before so the
first thing that I really like about it
is that there is a permission based
model here and so if somebody plugs in a
device and they go to a website in order
to connect directly to the button the
device via Web USB they actually have to
give that permission so it's very
similar to a webcam or your microphone
or your location I really like that and
you can actually kind of provide filters
so that you're only sort of showing your
device and they don't have to pick from
a list of weird random stuff that
they've plugged into their computer so I
think that's really accessible there I
think one of the best features is that
as soon as you plug in a web USB device
you have the option to provide a
descriptive on your device that is
advertised when it's plugged in and its
URL and so if your Chrome browser is
up-to-date and suppose
by OSB and you plug in a web USB you
know like compatible device it's going
to immediately pop up this notification
and it's going to say hey like I
detected this machine you should go to X
URL in order to connect so out of the
box someone has pulled this piece of
hardware out and they plug it in and
they immediately know where to go you
know to to start interacting with it and
I think that that's one of the single
most powerful features of this and I
love that it's just like a descriptor
that you set on the device but you're
probably thinking you know where
JavaScript developers and every
everything starts looking like a no
without JavaScript um oh and you know
why are we doing this in the browser why
we turn the turn the browser into an
operating system it's something that I
hear a lot so I I just want to talk
about some of the advantages there might
be and why I've being so pushy about
trying to make make this happen over the
last few years so in my opinion hardware
interfaces so writing software to you
know to integrate with your devices it
should be faster make it should be
cross-platform and it should be easy to
make a cross-platform it should look
good and it should be accessible you
know screen readers should be able to
see it this should be like in easy ways
in order to make that accessible in
every single platform without having to
like learn every system for doing that
as well right and browsers are really
commonly installed application on many
computers this doesn't necessarily
require like the person to be online
either you know if you wanted to try and
run something on localhost that will
actually work as well and browser-based
interface has just happened to be those
four things that I conveniently put in
the list before you can rapidly
prototype web interfaces that you can
hop patch them really easily and deploy
updates CSS is incredibly powerful to
make something look friendly and to help
you know organize information and things
like that and you have a consistent
accessibility tree if you make it
accessible you know in general in a
browser by respecting the wicked
guidelines and making sure that you're
making use of Aria features my needed
then it's going to be accessible to like
all of the different browser choices if
we're able to have web usb come to every
browser in the future and I think that's
actually really really powerful and
straight from the web USB spec with this
API hardware manufacturers will have the
ability to build cross-platform
JavaScript SDKs for their devices so you
know who likes the idea of the fact that
if really cool stuff comes out on
Kickstarter or like just you know is
made by big manufacturers wouldn't it be
cool if like we were considered a
first-class citizen and we immediately
got JavaScript SDKs to play with and all
we needed to know what's HTML and how to
do control transfers is that like you
know sending things they could give us
like a development kit that actually has
all of that stuff laid out and all the
for us to start using it I think that's
awesome so how do we use this I can hear
my friend Nathan in the back hi Nathan
he's so cute so you're using Web USB
it's a little bit involved because we
have that sort of user permission model
so I just wanted to step you through
this really quickly before we look at a
little bit of code so you've got your
user you've got your browser and they've
plugged their device into it and you
know the user could be you or it could
be like you know someone who's bought
your product and you want them to start
you know joining the two together you
want them to use their browser to
interact with the device the first thing
we need is a user event so they need to
do something like click or just
something intentional in order to start
the process with pairing to the device
once they've done that the browser will
then look for devices and we can give it
an optional filter such as the product
or the vendor ID so that we can actually
just fish out exactly what they're
looking for to help them out
it then returns any devices that are
plugged in that it finds that matches
those requirements the browser then says
hey I found this device I'm pretty sure
this is what you want do you give
permission for this website to start
interacting with it the user then
confirms the permission or they can deny
it or they can just like not do anything
close the tab which is a sometimes
coming with other permissions
but if they do confirm that permission
then we can immediately start opening
the device connection we can select a
configuration which you'll see in the
code very soon we claim an interface
which again is just like a term that we
use when we're using the web ESB
protocol so we claiming interface in
order to be able to start like using the
endpoints of that interface for your in
and out-out in order to talk to the
device and we finally start the
transference which is really really cool
but you know when you actually see a
demo of this which I'm hoping my demo
works it's a long story
but you'll see like that this actually
looks very fast it's it's more work for
the developer than anything but for the
user it feels pretty seamless so this is
part of the code for for getting started
you have your filters so you can see
here that I have a specific vendor ID
that I want to look for so this vendor
ID might belong to a company such as
Arduino or Adafruit or maybe it's your
own company we then I'm using fancy
async/await and because it's so so I'm
I'm basically just accessing the USB API
from the navigator object like how cool
is that it's directly in the browser and
so I'm requesting the device by passing
in those options it will eventually come
back and if it found you know some
matches then I'm gonna be able to look
at the device product name the
manufacturer name and things like that
so that's pretty cool so some of the
same code is at the top we request the
device we open the device once it is
confirmed to be opened we use our data
sheets for our devices which again is a
really cool thing to learn about to
select the right configuration we want
and to claim the right interface so the
interface is to do with like the
endpoints where we want to communicate
in and out so devices can have several
different interfaces so again you can
check your datasheet to find out which
one you need after that you can just
start sending data so I am doing device
transfer out I'm choosing the first
sorry the second endpoint on my
interface and I'm just sending the byte
like 0 sorry 1 a so I'm just sending
like 1 byte of information and that one
a might be an opcode it might
something like make a noise in my device
you know it could be start uploading
firmware or something like that it's
really up to the device manufacturer so
it's really hard for me to give you
super specific hello world examples
because it really does depend on the
device but then we can wait for a
response which is pretty cool by doing a
transfer in instead of a transfer out we
can supply the endpoint which is the
first argument and we can also ask for
how many bytes we want so I'm asking for
five bytes in this case and then we can
console.log out their response so again
if you're not familiar with the USB
interfaces this might be a bit like I
there's a lot of terminology here that I
don't know about but what I do like is
that it is built on existing standards
so you don't have to wait for people to
start writing blog posts about this
stuff you can go and read up on the
existing USB spec and start using kind
of more native libraries such as Libya
speak if you really wanted to to get
started and again I love data sheets
just want to take a moment to respect
how awesome they are and so they will
give you this information that you're
looking for and often it's in handy
table format so you can see here it's
giving you how many configurations there
are and things like that so if you see
that there's only one configuration then
you can just like pick the zero one
right so it will actually sometimes give
you that information and if you don't
know a lot you can just guess and
eventually it will work so yeah so I
didn't do a lot of hardware demos
anymore I tend to talk more on a variety
of topics but I'm sort of known for my
hardware talks so I'm gonna do some
demos uh-huh so we'll see how they go
these are especially fragile demos for a
couple of reasons so my first disclaimer
to you is that Web USB you know it's
changing it's new it's fancy it really
works in Chrome
and everything that I've made is on
weird get branches on my local computer
that I've deployed somewhere and some of
it was written on airplanes so it's not
fantastic the other thing is this is
literally where I was when I got a call
from Deus cough saying someone dropped
out do you want to give a talk
and I was like uh I don't really have
any of my stuff on me like I don't have
any of the stuff that I could you know
show how Web USB works or anything so I
did call in my friend Rick I was like
hey do you have all this stuff you're
coming to jail scones do you have a chip
that you don't care if I brick like and
he was really great so thank you Rick
for saving me today and I just wanted to
give him a quick can because thank you
so what I really wanted to do was I
wanted to show you the futures of Web
USB right I want it to be like here's a
chip you know it's a bit micro chip that
you know you can like you flick off an
hour dimino and sup programming and the
little the sort of like long red device
you see at the top is actually a
programmer and that programmer does
speak Web USB so theoretically you know
I was going to show you this thing that
uploads code to the chip and everything
but unfortunately this is all I brought
with me on my vacation and I feel like
that's still a decent amount to bring on
a vacation so I had a lot of stuff
there's been a lot of macgyvering over
the last few days so if you've seen me
intently like putting jump wise
everywhere and tweeting about needing
jumping jump was that was me trying to
get that really cool demo that I just
showed you here to work and I just
couldn't get it going I did half hack an
Arduino to get it to pretend to be this
programmer and I was like really proud
of that but yeah I just didn't quite get
there so I do apologize but I do have a
video of that demo but I do have a
different demo that you'll probably kind
of resonate with better anyway
so I'm going to show you that um really
quickly and then if we have time I can
show you the other video so you can see
that I have a camera focused on me that
is deliberate I don't like so I have
this device here so on the bottom is
like you can think of this as the
Arduino board this one is from Adafruit
it's the feather 32 u 4
it's a fantastic little device and you
can plug all these different sort of
like wings onto it will you just stack
them on top brick walls room was
fantastic and he brought me this triple
ax which just means that I can have them
side by side but they're still connected
to each other like this stacked this is
magical I didn't even know income by the
so this is a little screen here so my
aim is to use the browser to like send
something to the screen and then that's
going to be our happy demo for today so
I just wanted to show you this before
you plug it in and then I'm actually
going to go to my browser because
hopefully you'll see that that
notification comes up I can't find me
there we go alright so I'm gonna plug
this into my computer and then I'll hold
this up later just to see if it actually
works let's see oh alright so that's
pretty small don't clap no no no no no
that's not the Corvette but anyway you
see here it says feather 32-year for as
i said go to web USB dot fragile doubt
systems which is a domain name and that
I actually own it's meant for my demos
that are really bad like this okay okay
so my friend made this cool thing called
Oh lead Jas designer and then I like
fancied it up with a rainbow but I
although it would look like cool but I
also like hacked it to work with web US
base this previously didn't work with
web USB you could just design stuff
download it and then upload it to an
Arduino later so I'm gonna write
something real quick I'm gonna try so
hard not to go over time hi Jay yeah
this is really cool you should go play
with this just in general you know it's
like a pit ah'd but it's um for
monochrome screens so hi Jas kampf looks
terrible but I'm Russian
alright um so technically that means
that if we click connect
and cross our fingers oh there we go so
we have the LCD to you for right there
we're going to try and connect to it I
don't see what happens oh I saw
something it might actually work
okay so this is really hard to actually
do without kind of like losing the focus
of the the browser so let's see what we
can do huh
I don't have DV running right now I sort
of shot a bunch of stuff beyond alright
so I'm gonna click send image
and then that was not what I was
expecting to actually go wrong you know
what I mean like okay so I did a weird
thing where I go to cable stock I'm just
gonna have to like redo this I'm so
sorry geez just just building the
suspense you're welcome
okay so I have to like re refresh this
so okay so this is where I'm the second
thing doesn't work so normally when you
want to kill Johnny Five this is what
this is using you send just a control C
how do you do that in the browser it's
not it doesn't work at oh I lost my
screen I don't any minute now
yeah okay
I'm waiting for my confidence monitor
okay all right sorry oh my god I'm gonna
have to draw this again let's just
connect to it first huh
yep looks good to me hi this is gonna be
worse
crap I'm running out of time I'm so glad
I didn't bring the other damn right now
Jay s clump it's fine
okay so we're gonna hold this up and
then not screw up the AV the same Oh
I've tangled it again okay we ready
that works surprisingly well and I feel
like you clap louder than them so that
that's good okay all right cool
all right so that worked so that was
literally seamless because there was
just none of this fancy stuff like
gluing it all together it was just like
look there was this impacts and I want
to thank Louis for that because he wrote
the kind of hack that got Johnny Five
working with you web us because that's
actually not even supposed to be a thing
but he did really good at that so Thank
You Louis this is my other demo which
was oh yes like you Louis yes
cos he's here today and he was doing the
note copters yesterday who's awesome so
this is actually like what happens when
you try and program that bad chip so
this was the demo that actually worked
that I shot in my hotel room so you can
see there it read the program it got the
chip signature and each little hash you
see that he's like one page of memory
being written so I was able to even get
like the oh okay I wrote that page I
finished that page I finished this one
so like you can like make an ID natively
in the browser now and you can like
program microchips and stuff like I
mentioned just going to your own going I
don't know how to use this and like
there's like drag drop scratch
interfaces to like program these and
like I just I just wanted to tell you
how excited it was so yeah cool so demo
number one was made with Web USB serial
which was written by Lewis so yeah thank
you so much for that because it's
definitely a really cool hack
johnny-five was what I was using in
order to like write to the screen
I wrote the module to that actually the
kind of like jaws pitches and and can
send texts and stuff to the screen I
also wrote PNG to LCD which allows me to
also like upload bitmaps which I didn't
have time to show you but you could like
upload pictures of cats and stuff and it
will convert it Rachel my friends did
oled Jeff's designer which is Blom and I
used to with hack which was the weirdest
thing ever to do for hardware I think I
texted America and I was like I'm using
webpack for hardware I don't like this
world at all
I thought I'd got away with it for a
while demo number two is made with a
viago SDK 500 version 2 which is just
the protocol that the programmer speaks
that's part of my JavaScript hardware
repertoire I'm using a viago
ISP Mach 2 which is the programmer so
those two together and what allows me to
speak it and I'm using webpack and I
wrote that really bad code on a plane to
Australia a few months ago so I'm just
glad that it worked in the demo so
futures before I run out of time current
support let's talk about that sad so it
really wants to quit but what's cool is
that it works on Chrome for Android so I
have this really cool device that's too
small to show up here but you can like
if you can get one of those weird like
you know female USB to like male micro
USB you can like plug stuff into your
phone and just start controlling lights
and stuff so that's actually really cool
right so I'm hoping that this is more
green soon I work on myself so I'm
working on it I'm like winking at the
edge people and I'm giving them all of
these Web USB devices but I'm not sure
how much impact I'm having so please
tell browser vendors that you want this
stuff please help me because I can't do
this so why support this I feel like I
did a pretty good job of kind of showing
that but again just a draw from the web
USB spec this will be good for the web
because instead of waiting for a new
kind of device to be popular enough for
browsers to provide a specific API which
is kind of what's happening now new and
innovative hardware can be built from
the web from day one that's pretty sweet
you know you don't have to like wait for
these things so like anything can be
interfaced as long as it's just like a
regular USB which is a lot of devices
out there already so if you wanted to
learn more definitely again highly
recommend that you check out the web USB
spec it is hosted at the WCG github
repository and you organization you'll
find that at web USB my Arduino the
Arduino example will get you started so
I sort of was doing similar things in
that demo but I was using joining five
on top of that so please check that out
because it has step-by-step instructions
on sort of how to implement your very
first cool thing including like a web
page where you can just immediately run
it and as long as you've uploaded the
code to your Arduino it's good and my
demo is at that address there but again
it's like super shady code but yeah but
hopefully you'll enjoy reading it so
thank you
[Applause]